welcome to Downing Street for the daily
coronavirus briefing I'm joined by the
deputy chief medical officer Jenny
Harry's and by NHS England's medical
director for primary care dr. Nikki
Kanani first I want to take this chance
to update you on the latest coronavirus
data two million three hundred and fifty
three thousand and seventy eight tests
for coronavirus have now been carried
out in the UK including one hundred and
thirty three thousand seven hundred and
eighty four tests yesterday two hundred
and thirty six thousand seven hundred
and eleven people have tested positive
for the virus an increase of three
thousand five hundred and sixty since
yesterday ten thousand and twenty four
people are currently in hospital with
corona virus this is a thirteen percent
fall from the same time last week and
very sadly of those who tested positive
across all settings thirty three
thousand nine hundred and ninety eight
people have now died that's an increase
of 384 since yesterday and we mourn each
one the number of deaths is falling each
day in all settings thankfully and we
are past the peak of this virus and I
just want to take a moment to remind
everyone about our plans for this second
phase if we have slide one please we've
set up the nuke Ovid alert level system
that's their five levels of threat based
on the r-value and the number of new
cases the alert level in turn guides the
social distancing rules which are vital
in our efforts to control the virus a
higher alert level means stricter rules
throughout the lockdown we've been at
level four which means that kovat 19 is
in general circulation and transmission
is high or rising exponentially but
thanks to your shared sacrifice we
brought our down help cautiously and
carefully and responsibly we're now in a
position to
start moving to level three if we go to
the next slide please
we've set out the first of the three
steps that will take carefully to modify
the social distancing rules and start to
restore freedom to this country all the
while avoiding a disastrous second peak
that could overwhelm the NHS at each
step will closely monitor the impact on
our on the number of new infections and
on of course all available data and will
only move to the next step when we judge
it's safe to do so in the first step as
of this week if you work but can't work
from home you should speak to your
employer about going back in people can
now spend time outdoors and exercise as
often as you like and you can meet one
other person from outside your household
in an outdoor public place but please
keep two metres apart this weekend with
the good weather and the new rules I
hope people can enjoy being outside but
please stick with the rules keep an eye
on your family and don't take risks next
slide please
we've also updated what we're asking
people to do which is to stay alert
control the virus and save lives for the
vast majority of people staying alert
still means staying at home as much as
is possible
working from home when you can limit in
contact with people keeping your
distance if you go out 2 meters wherever
possible washing your hands regularly
this is still the most the single most
effective thing that you can do to keep
yourself safe and of course self
isolating if you or anyone in your
household has coronavirus symptoms by
staying alert and following the rules
you can play a part in the national
effort getting are down and keeping are
down controlling the virus so that we
can save lives
rebuild livelihoods and start to recover
our freedom as a nation from the start
of this crisis across the world
because this disease has a bigger impact
on the elderly there's been a huge need
to protect people in care homes we've
worked to do this in this country right
from the start of the crisis
this morning's information from the ONS
once again reminds us that care homes do
so much to look after our most
vulnerable people in their frailty
towards the end of their life many of
you watching this will have a loved one
in a care home as I do and I know how
worrying it's been so I can I want to
tell you what we've been doing to
protect people in care homes throughout
the crisis if we start with the data in
April 30 1203 people died in care homes
of whom eleven thousand five hundred and
sixty died with coronavirus I'm grateful
to the ONS for having responded to the
requests to put extra resources into
understanding and measuring all this
right from the start it's been clear
that this horrible virus affects older
people most so right from the start
we've tried to throw a protective ring
around our care homes we set out our
first advice in February and as the
virus grew we strengthened it throughout
we've made sure that care homes have the
resources they need to control the
spread of infection Social Care is a
devolved matter of course and this week
we've made a further 600 million pounds
available to care homes in England this
comes on top of the 3.2 billion we made
available in March and April and the 712
million pounds were made available to
the devolved authorities that's 369
million extra for Scotland 223 million
extra for Wales and 124 million for
Northern Ireland
we've put extra infection control
procedures in place and prioritized
testing in care homes we test any
resident returning to a care home from
hospital and all residents with symptoms
and all social care colleagues and
members of their
[ __ ] if they have symptoms together
these measures have saved lives and
protected 64 percent of care homes
almost two-thirds from having any
coronavirus cases at all and where there
are cases we've taken extra measures to
protect residents and staff with local
public health officials playing such a
critical role now we have capacity for
well over a hundred thousand tests a day
we're extending testing coverage still
further all care home residents and
staff in England
both those with symptoms and those
without are now being tested and in fact
will test every resident and every
member of staff in our elderly care
homes in England between now and early
June to get those tests to where they
need to be we've set up an easy-to-use
digital service on got UK allowing care
home managers to apply online for the
testing kits next we've strengthened the
NHS support available to colleagues in
Social Care and this is what Nikki is
here to talk about today throughout the
NHS has been supporting care homes with
infection control training and advice
and support on for instance PPE usage
we're putting in place a named clinical
lead for every care home in England
these leads are already connected and
will check in regularly to assess
residence and support care home staff
with clinical advice this is the most
intense support and scrutiny that Care
Homes have ever received in some cases
for residents who need to see a GP a
video consultation may be safer and just
as effective so the NHS is also
supporting care homes to introduce the
right technology this same technology
can and is being a being used to be able
to help residents stay connected to
their loved ones something I know is
important both for their well-being and
for ours third we're making sure local
authorities play their part we're now
requiring councils to conduct daily
reviews of the situation on the ground
in local care homes these reviews ensure
that every care home gets the support
they need
every single day and we're requiring
care homes to ensure the flow of timely
and accurate care home data so local and
national government can support and
where necessary challenge and act if
that's what's needed as a result of all
this and the work of so many people
across the social care system and across
the NHS and across local government
two-thirds of England's care homes have
had no outbreak at all the number of
care homes reporting their first case
each day has fallen from a peak of 219
to 59 I'm glad to report that since the
peak the number of kovat 19 deaths of
people in care homes has haft but whilst
this is progress there is so much more
to do and this crisis has also
demonstrated the imperative for reform
it's shown the importance of long
standing calls for closer working
between health and social care it's
acted as a catalyst for integration and
shown the benefits of it on the ground
information support and mutual
understanding between health and social
care are flowing better than ever before
helping to break down some historic
barriers
despite the system not because of it and
my view is that health and social care
have a common mission to care for people
but too often in the past bureaucracy
has held them apart from the start we've
worked incredibly hard to throw that
protective ring around our care homes
yes it has been difficult these viruses
reserve their full cruelty for those who
are physically weakest the elderly the
frail and the already sick all those who
most rely on human contact people who
live in care homes are amongst our most
vulnerable citizens
we'll do everything humanly possible to
protect them for as long as they are
threatened by this virus and thanks to
the collective efforts of everyone
watching we have passed through the peak
but there is still a long road ahead so
stay alert control the virus
and save lives